the retail world is changing so rapidly
and one of the goals I think of every
retailer today is trying to really
figure out what retellings going to look
like over the next five to ten years one
of the things that we believe very
strongly in is that on one side the
founding principles of our company and
the best merchandise assortments edited
from all over the world coupled with
great service and building relationships
with our customers will remain extremely
important but what is changing very
rapidly is how the customer likes to
shop and we're looking you know very
closely at how the customer integrates
her shopping online her research online
with her visits to our store and how she
then overlays her favorite social
platforms into her shopping experience
how important is discounting to her
since last call seems to be your biggest
growth area well I would say that
actually our overall ecommerce business
is actually our biggest growth area and
in our business discounting is really
shied away from except at our end of the
season sales when you know the fashion
merchandise that's been bought for a
particular season is marked down and I
think that the luxury vendors that we
work with on a daily basis they and we
have very high standards about how we
sell our product and the prices that we
sell our product and we really our goal
is always to sell the customer the
product at the appropriate price
throughout the season and then at the
end of the season to clear out those
fashion items that didn't sell as well
during the season Karen caster eyes
forward five years as this retail
landscape you've been talking about
transforms what percentage of Neiman
Marcus is revenue do you figure you'll
be generating online well it's hard to
actually predict what percentage
business we'll be doing online today
we're doing 25% of our business online
and I believe we're probably the leader
in department store penetration of
e-commerce to our retail stores and
obviously we think it's going to grow
bigger than that predicting the exact
percentages you know probably somebody
you know that's a soothsayer what I
think is actually more important than
the percentage of e-commerce to the
total business is really how customers
and how we as a retailer are integrating
the shopping experience for the customer
she really is demanding that there be a
real seamlessness between what she sees
online what she sees in the store and
how our messaging and marketing who
communication to her is seamless across
the channels that's our number one
priority over the next few years
you are a texas-based company the Dallas
Neiman Marcus is an iconic luxury store
how is the drop in oil prices affected
your business
well it's interesting we are based in
Dallas we are fortunate in our group to
have two great iconic luxury brands
Neiman Marcus being based in Dallas but
Bergdorf Goodman is also part of our
group and it's based in New York City we
are geographically spread throughout the
country so although we do have seven
stores in Texas and we are very very
proud of our Texas heritage we do have
seven stores in California seven stores
in Florida in the Midwest in the
Northeast so just as the economy goes up
or down in any one part of the country
or another we actually do have some good
hedging because of the way we're
geographically located are you seeing
tree are you seeing those Texas stores
get hit I think generally speaking the
Texas stores have been the strongest
over the last number of years and we
really aren't seeing any kind of real
decline in our business in Texas the oil
so what's happening what we see
happening in oil the stunning shakeout
in for example stock prices of oil
companies has to reflect what's going on
in the ground in Texas that has an
effective Neiman Marcus yet I think that
our customers as you might imagine
are tied in to a number of different
businesses the stock market is the most
leading indicator for our customers
health and well-being their balance
sheets are very very healthy right now
of course the oil and gas businesses
that are you know basically based in
Texas are either owned by or run by
people who are generally neiman-marcus
customers so I think that they're
probably being thoughtful about how
they're spending but again their overall
portfolio and their balance sheets are
actually healthier than they've been in
a long long time Karen I want to ask you
about Bergdorf Goodman you referenced a
Bergdorf's iconic presence here in New
York City on Fifth Avenue Neiman Marcus
is coming to town I wanted to know what
designs you might have for Bergdorf's
Bergdorf's is you know flirted with
expansion back in the early 1970s to
White Plains of all places but why not
take the Bergdorf brand in a
bricks-and-mortar way to Shanghai for
example ordered you to buy and make it
the international destination for luxury
the way it is here in New York City
well I'm very impressed you did your
research on the history of Bergdorf
Goodman we did have a store in White
Plains New York which about 30 years ago
we actually transferred that store into
a Neiman Marcus store and we've done
quite well in that location over the
years I do believe that the way you're
thinking about burgers is the way we're
thinking about Bergdorf's you know if I
could have any wish that I wanted about
Bergdorf's it would be to try to expand
it internationally it is more difficult
than it might appear on the surface but
I think you've hit upon something the
name I'm sorry will it take I couldn't
as I said I'm not a good in the
prediction business about those things
if I could have any Bergdorf Goodman
wish it would be that I would live on
the fifth floor if you had to choose
Neiman Marcus or Bergdorf's what do you
like more Karen oh my gosh that's not
choosing having a favorite having a
favorite child
we do have a choose my daughter over my
sons I choose Bergdorf's over Neiman's
what's your call okay well good for you
I I don't choose I don't have favorites
amongst my children so they are both
wonderful kids with very different
characteristics